Of course, we'll do a little quiz to have you figure that out.
What I would like you think about is the following:
I'm going to give you 3 graphs, and I'm going to ask you
for which of these graphs is shortest toward the hardest and the easiest to solve.
So here you have 3 graphs,
and each of these graphs has the same number of vertices
in case you're wondering, or at least I hope it does,
I counted twice, but you never know.
And what I want I would like you to tell me now
is for which of these graphs you think shortest tour is the hardest to solve
and for which of these graphs you think is the easiest to solve
and I've not written any distances on the edges,
but you can basically assume that I would be able to write
any distances that I want on these edges.
It's more of a question about the structure of these graphs,
and for the one that you think is hardest,
I want you to enter the number 3 in one of these boxes,
and for the one that you think is easiest,
I want you to enter the number 1,
and guess what number I want you to enter for the one that is in between.
So please, go ahead.